quand j'ai découvert j'étais séropositif
si oui en fait ça existe encore pour la
première fois de ma vie je suis assis
sur ma chaise et je sais il n'y a plus
rien le monde s'écroule c'est non c'est
non mais non c'est pas moi c'est
quelqu'un d'autre ça peut pas être moi
c'est juste ça ne peut pas être moi
c'est tout au début mes premières
questions ça a été mais est-ce que je
peux continuer à garder les enfants
est-ce que c'est pas trop dangereux de
quoi leur 2e bain de lait contaminé ou
que par un accident
tu vois que je me coupe truc totalement
qui ne pouvaient même pas d'arriver mais
quitte c'est ça qui fait flipper ils
disent et des enfants
[Musique]
pour dire on a envie par bibi sait très
bien que quand on prend
voilà une fois c'est pour réveiller non
pour y aller par quatre chemins
voilà j'ai voulu exorciser ans en les
peignant j'en sais rien c'était pour me
rendre compte
voilà c'est un petit pin pour trois ans
3285 que je vais prendre un traitement
pas de vie quelqu'un qui ne prendrait
pas le traitement aurait un risque en
quelques années que son système imiter
immunitaire se détériore et c'est à ce
moment là où par exemple une simple un
simple rhume ou une grippe pourrait le
tuer la personne
[Musique]
moi je suis séropositif indétectable ce
qui veut dire que ma charge virale n'est
plus détectable dans mon sang est donc
je ne peux plus transmettre le virus à
d'autres personnes ça c'est vraiment dû
au fait que je prenne un traitement
quotidien donc une trithérapie qui me
qui est en fait pour mon cas personnel
trois pilules que je prends en une seule
prise tous les matins
[Musique]
j'ai mal partout où j'ai mal à
l'intérieur lui défonce le corps des
professeurs
chacun son rôle est souvent le pechoux
salle des cauchemars à peu près toutes
les nuits
pendant toute une période
en fait j'étais j'étais vraiment moi
j'avais peur que en fait ça soit
vraiment quelque chose d'heureux butoir
est finalement bas j'ai réussi à
rencontrer quelqu'un et a rencontré
l'amour au final j'y pense plus presque
plus